there was a an ex Mason who was very
high up that wrote a book cremationary
light
and I can't say his name but when I
watched his video he said something that
really hit right between the eyes
he said the reason that the Shriners
burn Institute wants burned victims is
so they can traumatize them some more
and that's exactly what happened to me
[Music]
hey everybody Welcome to LED live I'm
here with my friend Roberta and she came
all the way from Washington
Oregon Oregon to share her story with us
and I heard little bits and pieces of it
and man it's just amazing to see how
some people go through some terrible
things but
God really got your attention and he
never gave up on you and that's
something that's part of my personal
story too is
that God never gives up on us no matter
how far we've gone he's always after us
and I'm sure along the way you've had
people come into your life that have
planted the seeds and that started to
grow but how did all this story happen
how did you get to where you are now
like take us back all the way to as far
back as you remember when all these bad
things in your life started happening
well there's this dear lady
um
she actually became a relative later on
uh because my son married
her daughter
and she was trying to take me through
the steps of freedom in this book
and as she did I had a flashback
of a dog's sacrifice
and when that happened
I started wondering some things there
was some crazy things happening in my
life attacks from demonic Powers even
though I was a Christian
and
the Lord was so good to be able to help
me figure out all these things that had
happened to me wow clear back when I was
three years old
so before that
you felt like as far back as you can
remember you've been a Christian and
life was pretty decent no okay the Lord
didn't get a hold of me until my
oh I think I was 24 years old oh wow
okay now I'm 72.
and as sharp as attack
and she even went ziplining with us as a
camp meeting that was fun yeah I got
burned in Kalispell Montana and I was
only three years years old what kind of
burn
third degree I mean that's the worst
there is yeah how did it happen wood
stove oh man
and uh my mom was a nurse there at
Kalispell working for a doctor and the
doctor told her about Shriners burn
Institute in Portland
so my parents bundled me up and we flew
to Portland and I was taken to Shriners
burn Institute
and
I don't recommend it for any child
because this is my story when they did
all the the graftings and everything on
me I was doing really great the only
where did this happen on your body
my back okay and on my leg
if it would have gotten my long golden
hair I would have not be here right now
wow my father grabbed a a blanket and
rolled me in it
and so
anyways when you do the grafting it's
painful
not bad and the only thing I could wear
is a diaper when I was only three years
old
you could not wear any clothes wow and I
was starting to finally get over all the
pain and suffering and now what I'm
going to relate to is actually a dream
the lord gave me shortly after my
husband died here recently back in 2021.
I had an event happen when I went up to
the arc Outpost when they were trying to
save my life over covid and put me
through a program to save my life and
after I got over the covid
I promised the Lord for the rest of my
life
I am going to follow you because I had
gotten anointed and the Lord healed and
now I said Lord I don't care what it
cost me
nothing makes me afraid ever amen
and
I am so thankful
how powerful God is and how my
grandmother my dear born again Christian
grandmother prayed for me for 22 years
because I believe she prayed the very
night that this happened
but you're there or acquired on several
months healing
and in the dream this is what happened
I Heard a Voice saying oh there you are
and these hands reached out and grabbed
me
well I resisted but then all of a sudden
you go limp because they stick a needle
in you um
and what the Lord showed me in this
dream is where they took me and what
they did to me in the Shriners Hospital
from the Shriner's house they took me
there's two corridors the Lord showed me
and one took you down to down to the
basement down below and that's where
they put me in a car and took me to this
Lodge and just for anybody that might
not know this the Shriners are linked to
the Freemasons correct yes they're high
they're higher up yeah yes
and um
in the dream the Lord showed me also I
was facing witches and warlocks Jesuits
Shriners I'm three years old
and what they do to a child is kind of
unmentionable
um and I went through this for several
months before my parents came and got me
out of there I had no idea how this
affected me until here a while back a
friend of mine asked me to go into this
praying room it was in in tongues type
of thing but I didn't think it was that
bad when I got in there I heard these
clicks I heard these things the very
thing I told the lady I said don't ever
ask me to go on that room again I said
this is what the witches did to me wow
so that was another regular wreck you
know remembering it and then I had a
dream
another dream before this one this was
my last dream I had but the one years
before when I went through the Awakening
of understanding about the the animal
sacrifice
the dog sacrifice
I was with an elderly girlfriend in fact
it was my mother's best girlfriend we
were in the same room together and all
of a sudden I start we were sleeping and
all of a sudden I woke up I woke her up
because I was screaming you're not
supposed to scream in a senior apartment
situation and she came over and and she
understood witchcraft because her
husband had gotten into it and she had
to fight for her children to keep him
out of Witchcraft wow because there is a
thing called witch calling and so anyway
what happened was is
she came over and she laid hands on top
of my head and started praying and I I
kind of woke up by then and I said he's
gone
I said who's gone
he's not bothering me anymore
and she said who's not bothering me well
it was a demon trying to scare me
and
how old were you then
well I was probably in my mid 50s by
then okay
because when I was with her yeah I was
in my mid-50s
and
so here's these things happening well I
got curious and I don't know if you know
about set the captive free by Dr Rebecca
Brown yeah yeah another book I've heard
it uh-huh
well
when I read in there how they marked the
child
now this is kind of gory but since a lot
of people are understanding about this
Blood drinking thing the adrenochrome
and all that the adrenochrome what it
said in the book was when they get a
child's blood and they got all the blood
in the world out of me you know I'm in
the hospital they always take blood
and anyway the high priest
warlock drinks
and then that gives access to for the
demons over that child
and the so-called power they gave me was
psychic powers
and I was really developing my psychic
powers when I understood some things
on the state of the dead and that
changed my whole life that's interesting
you're saying this because I'm thinking
about in the Bible where it says there
was a a damsel that was falling
following around Paul and somebody else
and she was saying these men are the men
of God but she was being a real
disturbance and uh they said that she
was a medium and that her powers came
from the Demonic world and when Paul
cast The Demon out of her she no longer
had the power so I'm I'm just trying to
reiterate some of this this is real it's
in the Bible that demons can give
somebody psychic powers whether that's
you know I think the demons there
watching everything and they're giving
you information it's not really a power
that's within you it's their relaying
information to you because you've given
them access in some way or another yes
when they Mark a child like that the
demons do come in and
I had Supernatural Powers I mean I had
Supernatural strength
I was one hard kid to deal with once my
parents got me back
but to go back one of the other things
you know they sexually raped the child
that's where they get their power yeah
there was a an ex Mason who was very
high up that wrote a book cremationary
light
and I can't say his name but when I
watched his video he said something that
really hit right between the eyes
he said the reason that the Shriners
burn Institute once burned victims is so
they can traumatize them some more
and that's exactly what happened to me
and how many months this went on I don't
know I just know that I went in there at
three I had a birthday there
and then shortly after that my parents
came and got me what what did your
parents think was happening did they
know they didn't have a clue so they
took you to the Shriners place and over
and over and come back and get you in a
few months I mean yeah but but as far as
being taken out of there that happened
over and over again the dream showed me
so they just thought you need to be
there to get well it takes a while to
heal just when you have Burns such
severe burns as I had and then you have
to have the graftings it takes a while
for those graftings to to heal enough
before the child can even leave the
hospital wow so I was there for a while
and so I went through this for quite a
number of nights um they would do it at
night but then once they did all that to
you well then they took some blood out
and this is what really in my dream I
saw that the doctors and the nurses said
the next morning where is
she's way down on blood and they could
it was puzzling to them
because you have to leave enough blood
to keep the person alive right but yet
take as much blood as you want
so there's some people that work there
that they don't know what's going on
they're just no the Lord showed me that
that the the doctors and the nurses were
totally innocent because I didn't think
that when he showed me that in the dream
that they were totally innocent I said
then I am sorry Lord that I have been
kind of rough on doctors and nurses over
you know thinking these things but
when
my parents came and got me
they had no idea that the child that
they just picked up is not the same
child they had
I was that powerful did this give you a
little instance of how powerful I was
to get me all the way back to Kalispell
Montana because this was in Portland
Oregon now we're going to Kalispell
Montana again
and I come home
and I've been away I want to see my big
brother
and my mother said no he's gotten
married
and they and he lives up the highway I
said well I want to see him tonight no
no Roberta and I said
I want to see him tonight and they said
no and they took me upstairs
well as soon as they left the room they
thought they had me laying down going to
sleep I went to the window
and I looked down and go oh that's a far
away is down there but I think I can do
it
so here I am four years old in a diaper
type situation climbing down a tree
walking down the highway and I found my
brother and I knocked on the door and
Dwayne opened the door and he said
Roberta
and I said I want Comfort I want Comfort
that's all I could say because I
couldn't like I said I didn't know what
they did because they erased the child's
mind
[Music]
and so
he picked me up in his big arms and
about that time the phone rang and my
parents said is Roberta there
and he said yep wow
and so my parents realized Not only was
I had some anger issues now
I was very sensitive and you couldn't
spank me because of all the burns no you
can't do anything with this child so
you're you said you looked down it was
really far down how did you get down I
climb down the tree okay
like I said I had superhuman strengths
yeah
wow a recollection of the psychic powers
happened not too far after that
I think oh it was a few months and I
told my mom I said get ready at knowing
he's coming and she was way over on the
other side of Montana over the mountains
and mother said we haven't heard
anything from her she's not coming well
guess who showed up no way at Noni uh
and my mother looked at that
and she was kind of hmm and then some
other incidents happen finally when my
got into my teens mother decided hey
because my mother
was a bachelin Christian
married my husband my my father who was
Cherokee I got Cherokee Indian
background that was why I was so
valuable
when you have those kind of powers
the demonics are after it that's all
there is to it yeah so anyway
so
my mother
got into astrology
and then I was doing psychic powers we
did it as a hobby we didn't do it as a
business or anything yeah but as the
child grows the powers grow with the
child so your mom was catching on that
you had this ability oh she was catching
on I had a lot of ability
and
so
she was starting to do all this
astrology stuff and I was into the
psychic powers and we were having a you
know she was working so she was gone a
lot
but
every spare moment we were doing
something like that we spent 60 dollars
on this one book wow and uh
my mom she didn't realize
anything
about how the Demonic Powers were
attacking my body mind and soul I think
one time she finally saw a little bit of
what I was going through I had disobeyed
my parents I went down to the theater
and I watched one of those very scary
movies it was about this
people in the future and it was about
cannibalism
and
she heard me screaming and this is when
I was probably about in sixth grade she
heard me screaming and she said what's
the matter I said those knobs on the on
that closet it looks like those
guys that were coming to get those
people to eat them and she said huh she
said did you go down and watch something
you shouldn't have watched I said yeah I
didn't go watch
the other stuff Mom I'm sorry
and so my mom remember she's Baxley
all of a sudden she described heaven
like you could walk around in it
and she said I want you to think about
this anytime you get scared and so that
helped with the fears but it still
didn't help with the Demonic attacks
those demonic attacks
happened on
at least every month I'd be raped by a
demon
and I don't think anybody understands
but in this book it talks about incubai
and it talks about what that can happen
to a woman and same with the saline for
the men the other book you mentioned by
Rebecca Brown yeah yeah she was the
devil's wife for a while yeah she was
yes
and um and then there's a book called
lamps to the slaughter
okay I've heard of that I don't know
what that is though I'll tell you one
little story out of there this happened
in the Midwest
it was an orphanage type situation so
she didn't have a mother and dad
when she got to be 10 years old was when
they took her out to the barn and the
witch is in the warlocks they raped her
over and over again
the poor little thing she's 10 years old
she's naked and then they tie her to the
fence post and say now the warlock's
going to come and eat you
so the poor little trembling thing is
this is in that book it talks about two
things one was a cannibalism thing a
little Tommy never made it but this gal
was tied up she's shivering she's afraid
and then all of a sudden a big Angel
comes
Angel Sent From Heaven and what does
that angel do he unties her and he sits
down
and he brings her up on his lap and he
takes his big wings and wraps them
around her
and holds her all night long
and just before morning
he has to tie her back up and he tells
her this now someday you're going to get
set free and I want you to help others
wow that lady has written a lot of books
it's amazing story yes it is I keep
thinking of things from the Bible when
you share this stuff like you mentioned
that you had a lot of strength that
happened with the demoniac he was
Breaking Chains a human was Breaking
Chains because of demonic power
and and this Angel setting the girl free
made me think of you know Paul and Silas
in the in the prison and they sing and
their chains fall off so yeah I mean I
just I want to bring up those stories in
case there's Skeptics you know they're
thinking uh how do I know this is real
you know it happened in the Bible we can
trust the Bible right amen we sure can
in fact I was thrilled
after I became a Christian when I
understood the Heavenly sings it
completely put me in a whole different
world
you know out of Darkness into His
Marvelous Light amen you know if I was
ever going to write a book that would be
the book yeah because that's exactly
what happened because I was pretty dark
have you considered writing a book yes I
have and I've had a lot of people after
me to write that book
and uh I think this is kind of unless
some some writer comes along and helps
me I
I don't know how to do it and I just
told the Lord I said I'll do this Lord
but I don't know about writing a book
but anyway to get back when on the angel
when I read that story I said to the
Lord I said why didn't you send an angel
to rescue me
and he said because of your sufferings
you've been able to help a lot of people
Roberta and I have there has been women
who have been through these horrible
things
and the minute I tell just a snippet of
my story they start crying and then I
start crying and I just hug them we
don't speak we just hug
and that's happened to me several times
amazing and then I meet these guys that
had young kids that have been into
occult things they seem to just come
like a magnet toward me for some reason
and by God's grace we're able to help
him I'll tell you this one story over
there at the ranch where I'm living
right now down in Oregon
over by the John Day River we went over
to spray which isn't too far away from
there to this home
in this particular Church
was having home church because it was
during covet and they were having Bible
study
well after the Bible well during the
Bible study I spoke up just a little
snippet of my testimony
and after that this young man walked up
to me and he said it's what you said
true I said yes
and he told me his story
how they had gotten him into this kind
of death Mexican cult thing they'd
gotten him to get all tattooed and then
they told him
that ink on you is more powerful over
you you're ours now and I blurted out
immediately the blood of the Lord Jesus
Christ more powerful than that ink and
you should have seen that poor depressed
boy light up like the Fourth of July
amen and currently I've been helping
that young man awesome in fact when I
get back to the ranch I'll be working
with him some more but this is how
powerful the message of the Gospel is
amen and for the gospel to get to me you
all had to work a miracle yeah I think
too many times we we care so much about
our comfort and everything that we think
why would God ever allow this to happen
but think of all the stories in the
Bible of people who went through bad
things for you think of Joseph he was
you know his brothers wanted to kill him
they threw him down in a well and then
he's getting imprisoned for something he
didn't even do but that didn't thwart
God's plan for his life and God brought
him to a place where he was you know
saving many people
but it humbled him you know there's
things that that happen in our lives
that make us
where we we have compassion for others
who have been there hey if you've always
had a nice car your whole life you'll
drive right past somebody that's on the
side of the road but when you've had car
trouble you feel like man I want to help
that person and same with anything you
know if you've been through an abortion
you have more compassion you've been an
addict you have more compassion for
people who struggle with that and so
yeah the Bible talks about many places
rejoice in trials and tribulations
because it's refining us it's it's
really a way that it's something that
brings us closer to God and it helps us
be more compassionate for others and and
reach them where they're at that's one
of the things
that
I was watching that video
you said Satan's shoes and shoots
himself in the foot because
us people who have suffered like this we
become compassionate and I am in The
Healing Ministry wow I have been doing
Healthy Living lifestyle counseling I
have been doing all these things for
what 35 years now awesome
and it's both spiritually mentally and
physically
and it's been amazing I have seen
amazing things how the Lord has blessed
but you have to have that love you have
to have that compassion
and that's what was created in me after
I became a Christian
I was just
absolutely in one moment created
completely Anew so how did that happen
so at this point your mom is my mom was
into that and then
I met this
wonderful
man when I was 19.
and I had no idea I was mirroring very
high up into a very powerful Church
and
so Jim
and I got married and then after I got
married
and
had our first son
you know the devil tries his best to try
to destroy you or destroy your child
and it was a miracle on his birth
because that cord was
completely choking him wow and if I
would have had that regular doctor you
might be dead to this day but because I
had this intern that knew what to do he
saved Daniel's life Wow
and so anyway after Daniel was born
there's something that changes in you
you have a desire you've got this little
human being now you've got
responsibility
but I was so selfish and so in my own
self and in my own world and everything
that I really didn't appreciate
and I still remember
hearing a little bit of the Gospel once
and so I had this Bible and I thought
well I'm going to find this information
couldn't find it so I took that Bible
and threw it clear across the kitchen
floor and I really believe that's when
the battlements of heaven and Jesus and
the angels we need to send her help yeah
because right after that this lady came
to my door she came in this cute little
dress
in such a humble sweet little gal with a
German accent
and she says I have these Bible studies
that you can do correspondence I know
you're a young mother and I told her
well they have to be of this particular
thing and she said oh it's for that kind
of Bible
I said really
and so because my husband had told me
nothing comes into this house unless
it's that particular thing and I said
okay
so I said yes I'm interested that very
first lesson I learned that I didn't
come from a monkey I learned I was
created amen
amen and that gave me a whole new idea I
looked at my baby totally different
right you know
and
then in these Bible studies we go on and
I don't know about you but
when it came to the Ten Commandments it
was the third one that hit me between
the eyes wow thou shall not take the
name of the Lord thy God in vain for the
Lord will not hold him yet let's take it
this name in vain
I spoke worse than a marine trooper I
was terrible in my language wow and yet
the Lord was merciful to me amen and
changed that just by learning that and
then we go on to the state of the Dead
That's when everything changed I mean I
was so much into fear of things I mean I
wore these certain necklaces to keep
Dracula away and all these different
things because I had these fears
it seemed like fear was something that
tried to just gobble me up
and you had went through a lot uh-huh
but
I just
when I learned what the Bible said that
the dead no not anything I said there's
no Dracula
I said there's none of this stuff
I said
hey
and only statutes and all this stuff you
know and I broke free
truth will make you free but nobody told
me I needed to renounce my powers
I didn't find that out until I got a
hold of a little book
it came from Australia and it talked
about renouncing powers
and I said why didn't somebody tell me I
would have been glad to renounce these
Powers did you ever feel like those
Powers came from God at all
no okay I know some people no because I
was too selfish and into myself I was
deep into yoga I was just on the verge
of really developing my
Powers through Edgar case's book
and I was starting to get into the
understanding reincarnation and all
these things when the state of the Dead
study came
and totally
Set Me Free amen but I wasn't a
born-again Christian yet yeah
I
still I was learning things I was
breaking away from things
but there still wasn't that love in my
heart
there was some knowledge now but not
that love one time they messed up on
those studies and they gave me a
different color it had different words
that I wasn't used to I had never heard
of the word revelation oh I only knew
the word apocalypse I hit the roof
and that dear dear lady bless her heart
Millie Bentley she came when she came
over and she saw how upset I was and
stuff and she said oh oh they gave you
the wrong lessons and all she had to do
is say one word that would have just and
it set me right off because when I heard
that word I said wait a minute you
promised me this would be this and she
said I'm sorry I'm sorry I'll get the
other back I said you better all I won't
do those studies and then she said and
she melted me she said oh by the way I
have a coat for your little boy no and I
said to myself I thought what was this
woman she is so sweet she's so
compassionate but boy when she prays
things really happen wow I thought what
is going on here anyway I I was happy my
lesson started coming the same blue
color because I love blue
and I'm doing the lessons and then we
hit upon a subject
and when we hit upon that subject
well I want to back up just a little bit
she lost me for a while
and she had prayed this prayer don't
give her peace or rest or anything until
she calls me it's exactly what happened
to me see through my powers
I could fast I could do all these things
and all of a sudden it was like I
couldn't control anything um
and so I found her phone number and I
called her up and she said where did you
move to you're not at the house anymore
I said well we moved into an apartment
we're having a low-income house built up
out there at Paradise Valley because see
Phoenix
is way on down there Phoenix Arizona is
way away from Paradise Valley but the
apartment we had just moved a few blocks
closer to her oh she said I'll be with
it over and within a half hour she was
at my door
and
she said do you understand the lesson I
said sure
and she said so you understand that the
seventh day is the Sabbath I said yeah
and she said you understand that
Saturday is the seventh day
is this sabbath
and I looked at her
and I said what
my calendar
it said one two three four five six
seven there was no way out of it the
seven was Saturday and I looked at that
and I looked at them one and I go looked
at that and I said
well it's a bunch of dummies going
church on the wrong day talking about us
that we're doing what we were doing
and she said
well let me show you some things and so
she did she showed me how the sap the
Sunday was changed I mean the Sabbath
was changed to Sunday
and that the particular church I was in
was responsible for it wow and I just
said
have a right to change God's word she
and she saw that I was really starting
to understand something so she took me
to a scripture
and it's right there in the Book of
Daniel 7 25 he shall think to change
times and laws
and that's exactly what I was learning
that Not only was time change but laws
were being changed what had been changed
while you're on the subject I want to
show you that that is happening again so
I've I've had these discussions with
people on social media you know that the
fourth Commandment literally says the
seventh day is the day that God rested
in the day that we should keep
and and I you know I'll show them hey
it's in the dictionary what you look at
your calendar it's the seventh day is is
Saturday
um and and now I used to screenshot what
the internet would say you can ask
Google or ask Alexa or whatever and so I
I saw when this changed but check this
out what day is the seventh day of the
week
standard ISO 8601 for representation of
dates and times states that Sunday is
the seventh and last day of the week
Sunday is the seventh day of the week
now this changed about three years ago
or so now the official answer that you
get from Google says this what's ironic
is if you ask
what day is the Sabbath
observed throughout the year on the
seventh day of the week Saturday
according to biblical tradition it
commemorates the original seventh day on
which God rested after completing the
creation
so it just told me that Sunday is the
seventh day of the week and now it says
the Sabbath is
Saturday the seventh day of the week
talk about confusion
isn't that interesting well this is how
I solved it but before she left she left
a promise and This Promise was so
powerful it's the first time I'd really
zeroed in on a scripture
Revelation 3 20. behold I stand at the
door and knock If any man hear my voice
and opens the door I will come in and
sup with him and he with me
well I thought okay
I'm not going to look at that pile of
books she just left me in fact I'm gonna
go hide him
and I thought I'm going to a neutral
source so I went to my dictionary and
sure enough it back in those days it
said it yeah it said the seven days
Saturday
and I said the Sabbath the Saturday hmm
I'm gonna go to my encyclopedia surely
my encyclopedia so I go to my
encyclopedia because when my husband
played ball for Houston Astros I had
gotten this Encyclopedia set and I
thought
I'll go to my Encyclopedia set so I go
to my Encyclopedia set and I look up
Sunday
of the sun whoa
interesting because one of the asanas I
learned in yoga was the sun worshiper
yeah the sun salutation pose and all
that I said
okay now I'm gonna look up Sabbath
um
and when I looked up Sabbath
it said the early Christians kept The
Seventh-Day Sabbath
this is what my encyclopedia says and
certain sex
inside the name yeah
Seventh-day Adventist and I said whoa
now you have to understand what you did
to me I based all of my
ideas of being somewhat of a decent
person and salvation if you want to call
it on a bunch of
sacraments and you just took that all
away wow and I fell on my knees and it
was no more Santa Claus prayers give me
this give me that is what is saving me
and that's when that Revelation 3 20 I
actually saw Jesus on the door
and I heard him say open the door and
then he showed me his high Priestly
Ministry in heaven
Heavenly things
and then I got flooded with this
acceptance I had never been accepted
even by my own husband bless his heart I
was such a wild thing he said I want to
change you a little bit I said can't you
just accept me as the way I am and I had
never really been accepted yeah I'd
always been such a troublemaker
and so here I was flooded with this
acceptance and it just flooded my heart
and it was just like
I was set free
those demons had to run yes they
couldn't stick around because all of a
sudden the Holy Spirit came in and to
give you any idea of how powerful the
Lord came into my life he gave me a
voice that to this day I sing for people
in fact it's a part of the healing that
I do for people is singing scripture
songs and singing hymns and things
and I got to think and I said wait a
minute I told the smelly Bentley I said
um
I think my aunt knows something about
this because when I went to Modeling
School
I remember my mother and my aunt talking
and my aunt was from Idaho
about this going to church on Saturday
thing
and I said hmm
you know that's kind of crazy but you're
17 you're tripping through you're not
paying attention
but years later all of a sudden he comes
and I said hey if my aunt knew something
about this
my grandma should know something about
this
and uh my grandma knew my mother should
know
and I went to my mother and I said what
is this why didn't you tell me and why
did you let me join that other Church
wow if you knew this
she said you were such a heathen I was
glad for you to get any religion all
right yes that was bad news yeah very
good looking bad news
and so anyway
poor Jim didn't have a chance
anyways so my mom said you know I really
feel I'm being called back
said okay if you're being called back
you want to do these Bible studies I'll
get this other kind of Bible studies for
you don't have to do the ones I was
doing
and she said yes
it took me nine months with my Bible
studies you know what my mom did six
weeks wow she was hungry she was but
she'd seen the change and she was also
being called back
[Music]
she was being called back by the Holy
Spirit and was told you tried to come
back when Roberta was burned
and you got blocked
and you were forbidden to ever share
with Roberta that The Seventh-Day
Adventists existed well
now
here's your last call
mother didn't understand what that last
call meant
but she got cancer and died two years
later wow
but she died in the Lord amen yeah two
years is is fast you know if she would
have put it off you know so many times
we'd say I'll do it tomorrow or not yet
we're not promised tomorrow
and your mom went race through those in
six weeks and only had two more years to
live because I knew so much and I could
expose so much I have
shot at poison tyrod's Nest was and
twice men have tried to come into my
camp and get me wow by God's grace I sit
here my man sane and sober
and the Lord has blessed because the
ministry that I'm doing now it's called
his grace mercy Ministries
has helped a lot of people in fact we
just saved a young gal from dying of
covid oh
that's how I got covered I was willing
to sacrifice myself to save her and I
went up north to this Arc Outpost south
of Chewelah Washington and they put me
through a special cleanse and saved my
life and that's where I got anointed and
then the next night my husband died down
at the ranch where my son was taking
care of him he had a massive heart
attack
back in 2016 he had four bypasses
he just didn't change soon enough for me
I have had to wrestle against powers and
they are real yeah
and up there at the arc I actually did
wrestle against some powers
and this is going to be the strangest
story I ever told in my life
because it's not a story it's true in
fact I have the glasses they recovered
the glasses out of the forest but to
save any child that would go through
what I've gone through I told the Lord
I'd go through hell itself and he asked
me one night when I was up there
up at the ark are you willing to come
out here in the forest and fight
and I said yes
you said are you willing to go to the
golden altar I said yes and I went out
there the Lord dressed me
you took the head covering off and I had
this leather skirt on and a red sweater
because this looked not cold out there
it was it was just before all this real
bad cold weather weather came
I had no idea I was resting wrestling
not against saving a child but actually
wrestling to save this institution I was
at the satanic Powers were not happy
that this Christian place
that had these dear dear black brothers
and sisters were saving people's lives
and really helping them so they were
trying to First the thing they did is
cast a spell on his wife and she got
lupus and had to leave with the two
younger children
and here he is with the older children
and a small little group
trying to carry on a big Institution
and here I come along as sick as I was
and they got me well in one week we
kicked coveted in one week between the
drinks that put oxygen in me and the
other things that we did that I know how
to do
we kicked it in one week that's awesome
so I'm out here in the forest and I'm
wrestling
and I'm rebuking and I'm binding and if
you don't know how to review combined
you can't even deal with satanic
spiritual warfare it is spiritual
warfare
and they told me
because I was dealing with two spirits
one of a warlock and one
and I knew the witch's name
because I had dealt with that particular
High Priestess down in Hefner when you
went to the forest you saw actual people
there no okay but this those Spirits
were speaking to me because they came in
spirit form you have to understand
there's a war out there and Heaven had
already promised me that if I would go
out there that
they would make sure they couldn't kill
me
they could do things to me but they
could not kill me like job
and I went out there and I was rebuking
and binding and the closer I got to a
certain area apparently where they did
not want me to go to they said if you
come any closer we'll throw you up in
the air I said I don't care and they
threw me up in the air wow
and I landed and that's when I lost my
glasses
and I got up back on my feet again this
is in the dark you're in the dark you're
out there I think you have Moonlight
yeah yeah and there was some kind of
weird lights here and there I get up and
I'm rebuking and binding this was from
Midnight to six o'clock this battle went
on
they said uh
don't come any closer
and I came closer again and was rebuking
and binding I says nothing is going to
stop me amen and then they threw me up
again now I have metal in my neck
because we had an accident years ago my
husband rolled the truck it was not his
fault it was a combination of heat and
you didn't have your
um seat belts belts in those days
um my neck was
subletted so it was wired together so
I've got lots of wire in my neck and in
fact we found some interesting things
out about my neck but anyway I heard
this when I landed I felt this Zing it
was like they were trying to paralyze me
that didn't stop me I got back up on my
feet and grabbed onto the tree and was
rebuking and binding and telling them
you are not going to have these Powers I
will not let you do this to Children
anymore I will fight against you with
everything I have then they said don't
come any closer and they threw me up a
third time when I landed that time
and it kind of knocked the breath out of
you a little bit now you have to
understand I've just gotten over covet
I'm 72 years and not 71 years old and
I'm out here in this Forest when I
landed that time
I was still was determined there's no
way you're going to stop me and I got
back up and I started walking again and
the fourth time I was thrown up in the
air
and this time when I landed I was done
it I Heard a Voice from Heaven saying
it's over um
you don't have to do it anymore
and I said did we win you know and I
said Lord I don't think I can get up and
the Lord said no I want you just to turn
on your knees and I want you to crawl
over there to that light
I don't know how far I crawled but I got
to the building I'd left the institution
and
I said okay Lord I'm standing up now
because I was leaning up against the
building I said where do I go and he
said see the light I said yeah
go for the light well apparently
meanwhile while I was out there in this
Forest doing this Somebody went into my
room and found I wasn't there and they
called up my daughter
oh she hit the roof wow my daughter is a
nurse and she thought this was very
irresponsible that you would let this
happen to her mother and oh boy she was
fit to be tied
came to this light and here was the
worker that had helped me because when I
first arrived I was so ill he had to
just scoop me out of the car and carry
me upstairs to my room oh man
and here was Calvin and he said Roberta
go to the door it's right there and so
I'm feeling my way and I get to the door
and
the door opens and he grabs me and he
carries me upside upstairs and sets me
down in this chair in front of
gandor and gandor says Roberto where
were you
it says out in the forest why were you
out in the forest well if I told you I
don't think you'd understand
I was
fighting or against powers and he kind
of shook his head you know and he didn't
quite understand what I was saying they
had notified my daughter I'm okay
and so I'm taking back up into my room
and boy the next morning I'm sore I mean
I bet that I was pretty sore I don't
know how you understand this but the
Lord can communicate things to you that
things are going to happen to you and
this is exactly what happened the Lord
said you're going to be visited by the
Warlock the spirit of the Warlock
and sure enough I had about that wide of
of the window open
Spirit came through
and he's in front of me he's a good
three feet away from me maybe even five
feet you old bird we should have burnt
you a long time ago I said you didn't
and because I'm alive I'm gonna tear
your kingdom down and I don't care what
it costs me
there's nothing you can do to stop me
either I'm the little Cherokee baby that
got away
and that was
back in 2021
in the winter
before the snowstorms
and the Lord is
giving me other people to help
and
so when we're able to come this
direction I told my friend I said
well
I think I'm gonna go visit little light
yes I says I want to see little light
because I was so impressed with the
ministry I said here's somebody that
finally understands yeah I was gonna say
you've been in that you've seen the
darkness and it needs to be exposed you
know Satan is
deceiving the world it says the dragon
is going to deceive the entire world and
it's like the world just has blinders on
I remember when I was a self-professing
Christian and I could not see that
something as simple as like Harry Potter
was pushing witchcraft I just I heard
some Christians say that kind of thing
but I was like man it's Fiction it's
fairy tale you know like I I couldn't
see and then December 2011 it was like
the blinders just fell off and it was
like everything I believed was a lie or
whatever it was just like it turned my
whole world upside down which is what
you were saying happened to you
and it's just amazing like you said you
wanted to write this book called into
His Marvelous Light you know from
Darkness Into His Marvelous Light that's
the
that's just the way it is with God it's
the truth makes you free the
he is the light and and at the beginning
you said that you don't have any fear
because perfect love casts out all fear
amen and if we're on his side there's
nothing to fear even even if they take
us physically they they harm us
it's all worth it we're gonna get to
heaven we're gonna say it was all worth
it amen there's many people have burned
at the stake for the truth and as long
as we stand on the truth we will never
be ashamed
God keeps his word he keeps his promise
if we endure to the end we will receive
a crown of life and that's the greatest
gift that anyone can have
eternal life that's what everybody wants
and we're only going to get it if we
serve the King of Kings amen and
I never want any child to suffer like
I've ever suffered and I've warned every
mother that's ever taken a child to
Shriners you stay with that child 24 7.
yeah I said you don't leave that child
sign for one minute yeah got such a
hunger and a thirst to try to help any
child get set free from the Sun Tanning
Powers because I know what it's like to
be abused by the demons
and
to to just to hear that young man say
free
it's not you know
I
I you just gave me the understanding
that the blood of Jesus is more powerful
than what they've done to me
and I said yes and you need to get into
the word and hide it in your heart amen
I want to end with a song If it's okay
yeah definitely it's a call actually go
through go through the gates
cast up cast up
gather out the stones lift up a standard
for the people and they shall call them
the holy people Lord redeemed of the
lord lord redeemed of the Lord and they
shall call them the holy people Lord
redeemed of the Lord
that's in Isaiah 62 10 and 12. amen that
was beautiful and that's the voice the
lord gave me when people
it would be all after you trying to get
that voice
uh yeah I made the mistake of
talking to a guy from Hollywood has been
singing his song over the phone it was
one of my son's friends he said oh I
gotta have that voice
Satan's trying to get after the talent I
said no lord it's yours I only sing for
my king now that's right wow thank you
so much for sharing this amazing story I
know that somebody out there is going to
be blessed by this you know there's a
lot of people whose spouses have gone
prodigal their children are going into
this darkness and stories like mine
Roberta's shows that no matter how far
in the darkness you are God never gives
up on you he keeps going after you and
us being as Christ you know we're
Christians we're supposed to be like
Christ
we need to do the same thing we need to
you know never look at somebody and say
look they're never going to get it we
need to love people the way Christ does
we need to have a unconditional
overwhelming love and be a shining light
in this dark world I thank you so much
for for joining us if you like this
video if you were blessed by it give it
a thumbs up it's a simple and free way
to really help this ministry it helps
get the video into the algorithm so more
people can see it if you're not a
subscriber click the Subscribe button so
you can see more videos like this and
don't forget to share with families and
friends and if you want to support this
ministry you can do so by going to
littlelightstudios.tv towards slash
donate and we really can't do this
without you it's only possible because
of viewers like you who help and support
we love you and we'll see you next time
on LED live
thank you
[Music]
foreign
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
thank you
foreign
[Music]
but do you have time for God do you have
five minutes
[Music]
hey YouTube what is humility
hey YouTube What is love
hey YouTube why does God allow suffering
because when you die video Bible study
answers your questions in five minutes
or less
hey YouTube how do I study the Bible
hey YouTube can God give forgiveness for
my sins do you have questions like this
then I highly encourage you to check out
the Channel video Bible studies
I dare you to spend five minutes with
God if you're looking for a way to
spruce up your wardrobe this year check
out lightwear dot shop it's a
christian-owned apparel company with the
belief that we are all walking
Billboards one of the best ways to share
your witness is to wear your witness
these conversation starter designs are
the perfect way to look good while
shining your light for Christ for a
limited time use promo code love for 15
off your entire order that's 15 off for
new clothing for you and maybe a gift
for someone special so go to lightwear
dot shop and remember use promo code
love
[Music]
thank you